details for cyberpunk 2077's expansion
may have leaked and the witcher 4 gets a
development update
according to vgc which has seen the
leaked files and first reported them
hundreds of lines of dialogue spelling
out most of the events and characters of
cyberpunk's expansion have appeared
online the dialogue points to a
datamined character named songbird as
the focus of the dlc the report says the
side missions seem to mostly contain
placeholder text but enough of the
dialogue throughout shows that johnny
silverhand may have less of a presence
in the expansion so instead it seems
like songbird may serve as players new
guide as they're taken through its
reported seven missions various side
missions and world encounters and this
will all reportedly take place in the
combat zone and the sports dome which
were both previously inaccessible spots
across night city so what do you think
of all this info are you excited for the
expansion are you holding back your
excitement until you see some gameplay
and stuff let me know and in other cd
project red news the developer has
announced that the latest installment of
the witcher saga has completed its
research phase and is moving forward
with development this means that the
witcher 4 could be entering
pre-production relatively soon at which
point cd projekt red will figure out the
structure and scale of the game among
countless other details the announcement
came way of the polish developers q1
2022 earnings report where among other
projects it commented on the status of
the witcher 4 which was announced in
march all this to say that the witcher 4
isn't coming anytime soon and that's
okay my heart really needs this game to
be perfect or close to perfect perfect
doesn't exist and even though the new
witcher seems so far away the new god of
war just keeps getting closer nigel on
twitter spotted a rating from korea's
ratings board for ragnarok it doesn't
include any information about the game
but receiving a rating suggests that the
game is well advanced in development the
game has not been rated so far in the us
by the esrb but it's not uncommon for
ratings to emerge in other countries
first as was the case with mafia 2's
definitive edition among others but i
know what you're thinking devonte i
don't have a ps5 yet is it coming to pc
well i can't answer that for sure but
what i can say is that sie president jim
ryan has said that the company expects
half of its annual releases to arrive on
pc and mobile platforms by its 2025
financial year which runs from april
2024 through march 2025 so it's
definitely not useless for you to wish
for a port of ragnarok in the future
however the next playstation exclusive
that seems to be in line for a pc
release is return a steam db listing
called name oregon contains tags and
descriptions that match returnal's world
and gameplay mechanics for example it
contains keywords that point to the
endless mode that was a part of the
game's last expansion return ascension
the latest expansion also brought co-op
and daily challenges to the game which
the steamdb listing also has keywords
for lastly the listing has the key words
atropos and helios the former is the
planet where returnal takes place and
the latter is the name of the ship that
the main character celine crash lands on
the planet with sony hasn't made any
formal announcements about a pc version
of eternal but it could show up at a
presentation such as a state of play or
even during next month's summer game
fest so will you play return when it
comes to pc personally i'm waiting for
the new playstation plus to drop in
north america so i can play it for sort
of free but if we're talking about real
free bioshock collection is free on the
epic game store right now and i've never
played it mouse and keyboard so i'm
about to jump in and have a blast
bioshock 1 is one of my favorite games
of all time so
here we go i'll see you in the next one
you